وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي زادت من
التستخدام وانتشار الاخبار المزيفه
والكاذبه حتى انها تجد طريقها الى وسائل
الاعلام الرئيسيه ايضا لكن اللغويين في
جامعه اوصلو النرويجيه مع خبراء الذكاء
الصناعي يعملون على فتح لغه الاخبار
الكاذبه والمزيفه والتي يسمونها ثانك
فاثناء البحث تبين ان نصوص المزيفه تكون
مختلفه من حيث اسلوب صياغتها بالاضافه الى
العديد من الاختلافات اللغويه الكبيره
فمثلا كان للنصوص الزائفه اسلوب غير رسمي
اكثر كما لحظت في النصوص المزيفه كثرت
استخدام الافعال خاصه في زمن المضارع
بالاضافه الى ذلك كانت الضمائر والصفات
والكلمات والتدخلات ملونه
مختلفه بالهدف في مكافحه الاخبار المزيفه
على الانترنت وتحسين ادوات التحقق من
صدقيات هذه المنشوره
[موسيقى]
طيب احنا نسال سؤال انت كخبيره بالموضوع
هل بالفعل للاخبار المزيفه والكاذبه لغه
يمكن ان تكشف
يعني بحسب الخبره يعني بنشوف فيها الاخبار
المزيفه بنلاحظ انه النصوص اللي بتستخدم
واللغه التي تستخدم بالاخبار المضلله او
المزيفه
بتعتمد مختلف يعني بنلاحظ انه
تستخدم لغه عواطف اوقات لغه ركيكه تستخدم
دائما صيغه المجهول او النفي همم الغضب
مسيطر احيان كثيره يعني فينا نقول انه
الاوجه تبع همم اللغه بتختلف بحسب هدف همم
التواصل الاجتماعي انتشرت همم بسرعه
الاخبار الكاذبه والاخبار الزائده فانتم
كخبراء في هذا المجال ماذا تنصحون
المتابعه العادي ليكشف الاخبار الكاذبه
والذئب عن الاخبار السابقه همم اولا
ودائما من نصف انه همم نلجا الى المصدر
يعني الخبر الذي ليس له مصدر نحن بنجرب من
صدقه وما من شربه همم ايضا الانتباه ل همم
للتفاصيل الصغيره بالمنشورات في الاحيان
بيدعوا المروجين للاخبار الكاذبيه لنا
مثلا تجري باوقات محدده او مثلا باميكن
همم محدده من العالم
ولا امور الصغيره بالصوره او الفيديو تشير
الى اصدقاء في اماكن اخرى همم بالاضافه
الى ذلك همم في كثير من المستخدمين اليوم
وخصوصا انه العالم عام معلوماته بشكل اكبر
من مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في كثير اشخاص
عم يتنبه اهو لا انه المنشورات مزيفه وعم
بيعلق بيخانه التعليقات للقول انه هذه
المنشورات مزيفه فمش غلط ابدا
ضاع الى تعليقات المستخدمين اذا حسينا
احنا بدنا نشارك هذا منشور همم وايضا اضيف
انه في حال نحن شكلنا او جينا شك صغير
بانه المنشور مضلل فينا ببساطه عدم
مشاركته لان المشاركه اليوم بتكون عم
بتسهم بانتشاره
[موسيقى]